well very often we hire the same way we
uh recognize and reward people which is
we only look at their past performance
for other companies you know we look at
their resume did you work for my
competitor do you have the skills and
that's you know we and
that's basically it and we've
all hired people who were great on paper
and great in the interviews but then
when they got to us
it just didn't work we struggled even if
they were talented
the egos were in the wrong place
whatever it was
and so
it's just like dating which is you want
to get a sense of someone's character
i'm a great believer
that when if someone is doing well in
the interview process at some point you
want to
go out for a coffee with them
socially as part of the interview
process not not at the office
where you don't talk about work or what
they've done you talk about their family
you talk about what they do in their
private life and you get to know them
and and you and you start asking
yourself
do do i like this person do i want to
spend time with this person do i could i
could i see myself trusting this person
again it's a little bit like dating you
know um but i think to to have some of
the more casual interaction is actually
very very revealing and you get to learn
about how someone thinks or treats uh uh
the people around them in addition i
think the way we write our want ads you
know looking for a
uh an engineer x amount of years of
experience you know must know these
languages you know please apply
okay well that tells us very little
about who they are versus uh saying
describing your culture right
if you like working in a team where
people take care of each other
where people are honest with each other
where we give honest feedback and we
like to receive honest feedback um you
know we we may have a great job for you
do you know how to code do you know how
these languages how many years of
experience do you have please apply
and the point is is the description of
what it's actually like to work there
the description of the culture will
immediately turn some people on and
immediately turn some people off
and that's exactly what you want and you
want to be brutally honest about what
it's like to work there the good and the
bad and the ugly uh because again
uh that's what they're actually going to
experience remember in the interview
process they're selling themselves to us
but we're selling ourselves to them as
well you know the number of times
companies will say oh it's it's like a
party here every day well
sometimes and then sometimes it's really
like a dungeon you know
and i think it's okay to say that look
we work really hard and there are days
that sometimes dark but in the dark days
where what you'll find is that we're a
culture that takes care of each other so
yes we have stress but you'll find that
the camaraderie is incredibly high you
know we can say that as long as it's
true because they're going to find out
the truth any moment
so yes i think we should recruit
with honesty and we should recruit to
tell people about the kind of conditions
they're going to be working and tell
them the culture not just the job
requirements